going to give you the forecast which is
actually going to be a very nice 4th of
july right you've been here long enough
to know that it gets hot on the 4th but
today looks great we've got temperatures
in the 70s and 80s this morning
humidity is only a little over 20
percent winds are on the light side for
now
but they will be picking up again so the
national weather service has left that
fire weather warning in effect through
today all the way until this evening so
that's all of southern nevada please be
careful with barbecues fireworks
anything that could get a fire started
once these winds start picking up again
would be very difficult to get that fire
out high today of a hundred degrees for
our july 4th you know we've had years
past where we've been in the one teens
in the afternoon so this is really a
nice break for us especially because
it's so nice and dry but it is going to
be dry and that means you're going to
need to stay up on water today so have
lots of water for pool parties barbecues
for fireworks this evening we're looking
at the about low 90s for later this
evening between seven and nine when all
those fireworks are going off and
hopefully you're going to the great
shows where the casino resorts will be
putting on all those spectacular
fireworks uh this eight day eight days
forecast uh the beginning of the week
looks great we're up around 100 degrees
and then a steady increase in temps all
the way to 105 on friday and even 110
plus maybe by early next week that's
when it gets hot you guys i know we're
so lucky it's gonna be a fantastic
fourth everybody just keep yourself
hydrated and cool take good breaks out
of the sun and you'll be all right today